what's up my name's Jonathan know-it-all
and when I get high get ideas about life
[ __ ]
look at the job in the world hi Diaz of
the day I love how there are still
people there protest against medical
marijuana how did you hurt it's not as
bad as cigarettes alcohol alcohol kills
about 75,000 people a year
obesity [ __ ] just eating food
kills about 300,000 people a year
cigarettes kill about 6 million people a
year you want to know how many people
died of marijuana a year not one there's
not one death linked to marijuana and
there's thousands of years that's been
around done I love how people are
willing to touch alcohol and cigarettes
but when it comes to weed that's the
Dale let's get real for a second
remember that time when Mel Gibson got
pulled over a Malibu it was drunk off
his Australian ass if the [ __ ]
had been high instead of drunk with
complimented the Jews instead of
attacking them Mel Gibson had a
marijuana addiction as opposed to an
alcohol addiction
I'm sure its career would not be a big
piece of [ __ ] right now instead of I
hope you get right fire pump inwards he
would have been like we should have an
orgy with a group of Blacks and Jews
probably wouldn't happen look bottom
line we don't kill we'd has a lot of
benefits it helps with where the [ __ ]
was I talking about
Alzheimer's disease he'll soon epilepsy
headache sack pain glaucoma arthritis it
helps with depression see look at me I
want happy [ __ ]
it helps with a lot more [ __ ] - look
what I find the most surprising is that
most people who say weed is bad for you
really don't know why ask them what they
think that here's what they'll say I
don't know it just is idea of the day
know your facts about weed before you
start calling it a bad deed that's right
I ride now suck my dick
you
you